[Musica]
[Applauso]
sono arrivato qui a lerici nel 2013
questo angolo di paradiso
per studiare questi animaletti qui per
studiare il plancton dal greco planctus
the wonders i vagabondi coloro che
girovagano
lavoravo all'interno di un grosso
progetto europeo che si occupava di
studiare la connettività fra le aree
marine protette del mediterraneo e come
le varie aree marine protette del
mediterraneo fossero collegate tra di
loro attraverso le correnti marine
superficiali e per studiare come questi
meravigliosi animali che sono la base di
tutte le catene alimentari marine e si
spostano da un area marina protetta
all'altra sulla superficie del
mediterraneo usavamo questo strumento
qui si chiama reti non è houston è un
nient'altro che un retino con una maglia
molto fine che raccoglie al suo interno
tutti questi microscopici organismi
questo rettino viene trainato da di
solito da una nave oceanografica per
qualche minuto è un campione di plancton
una volta che viene portato a bordo
delle nostre navi pulito dovrebbe
apparire più o meno così c'è una massa
gelatinosa in forme di microscopici
animaletti che se osservati al
microscopio rivelano tutta la loro
magnificenza
sin dal primo campione che abbiamo la
continuità la neo però ci apparso subito
chiaro che la situazione era ben diversa
questo è stato il primissimo campione di
plancton che io ho raccolto sulla
superficie del mare adriatico nel 2013
appare subito evidente quindi riporta
degli altri esempi come al di là del
plancton degli organismi che eravamo
interessati a studiare c'era
qualcos'altro
centinaia una miriade di frammenti
colorati diversi di plastica le
cosiddette microplastiche quindi
frammenti di plastica più piccoli di 5
mm e quindi porte o anche questa
immagine di un campione che viene
raccolto al largo del golfo di napoli
sempre tra il 2013 e 2014 e con una
scritta che direi quasi profetica
insomma non so se riuscite a leggere
enjoy packaging
c'è
abbiamo capito quindi che c'era qualcosa
che non andava sulla superficie del
mediterraneo abbiamo incominciato a
voler descrivere il problema a voler
quantificare voler adottare appunto un
metodo scientifico
studiare nel dettaglio le
caratteristiche di queste particelle
quantificarle qui vedete la
distribuzione di tutti i campioni che ha
raccolto nel corso di quegli anni a
bordo delle navi oceanografiche in giro
per il mediterraneo
poi ci sono voluti anni di lavoro di
duro lavoro in laboratorio per
quantificare contare analizzare e
classificare ogni singolo frammento di
plastica raccolto dal nostro lettino e
alla fine dopo anni di lavoro abbiamo
pubblicato i risultati di questo studio
su una rivista che molto prestigiosa e
l'abbiamo intitolato the mediterranean
plastic su la zuppa di plastica del
mediterraneo che ahimè non è una ricetta
di pesce ma è purtroppo la situazione
attuale della superficie del mare nostro
di uno dei mari più belli del mondo è
quella che vedete qui in fotografia
correva l'anno 2013 come vi ho detto
all'epoca in realtà si sentiva parlare
ancora molto poco di microplastiche
oramai sono sulla bocca di tutti però
nel 2013 c'era solo una manciata di
articoli scientifici come vedete da
questo grafico pubblicata sull'argomento
nonostante i ricercatori della già dagli
anni senza 77 60 70 che segnalavano la
presenza di questi di queste particelle
sulle superficie del mare di lì a
qualche anno l'interesse della comunità
scientifica è del pubblico di pari passo
e cresciuto esponenzialmente
io mi sono trovato letteralmente nel
mezzo
parallelamente la produzione e il
consumo globale di materie plastiche
aumentava esponenzialmente anche gli
equi nel grafico a destra potete
apprezzare il trend di crescita della
produzione di polimeri sintetici
d'altronde il problema non poteva
passare inosservato perché pensate che
la massa in termini di peso di polimeri
sintetici prodotti dall umanità dal 1950
quindi abbiamo quando abbiamo inventa
quando abbiamo inventato questi polimeri
ad oggi equivale in termini di peso al
doppio della massa di tutti gli
organismi marini e terrestri messi
insieme
produciamo tantissima plastica e
inevitabilmente una parte una frazione
di questa plastica da di riavere una
piccola frazione di questa plastica
finisce in mare ogni anno si stima che
finiscano negli oceani di tutto il mondo
circa 8 milioni di tonnellate di
plastica all'anno questa è una cifra
gigantesca per darvi un'idea dell'ordine
di grandezza vuol dire che un camion
della spazzatura viene riversato
interamente in mare ogni minuto di ogni
giorno dell'anno ma quello che io trovo
veramente terrificante è che questa
quantità di plastica corrisponde
esattamente alla quantità di tonno che
noi preleviamo dai mari di tutto il
mondo ogni anno 8 milioni di tonnellate
di tonno ogni anno vengono rimpiazzate
da 8 milioni di tonnellate di plastica
io sono un ricercatore mi piace come von
humboldt qualche secolo prima unire i
puntini per trovare delle risposte
per cercare di rispondere a una domanda
importantissima cioè che fine fa questa
plastica una volta che finisce in mare i
ricercatori sono andati in giro per il
mondo ne compreso ho passato più di 500
giorni a bordo di nave oceanografica in
giro per il mondo quella che vedete su
questa mappa e la distribuzione di tutti
i campioni di micro plastica raccolti
nei mari di tutto il mondo nel 2014
balza subito all'occhio che c era ci
sono delle zone completamente
inesplorati mi riferisco in particolare
alle zone polari al polo nord al polo
sud non sapevamo quanta plastica c'era
in queste aree del mondo se ci era
arrivata e tramite quali meccanismi
ma perché proprio il polo sud vi faccio
vedere questa immagine che trovo molto
bella e la proiezione di spilla o se una
un punto di vista inusuale sul nostro
pianeta
che contrariamente diciamo quello che
siamo abituati a vedere tutti i mari del
mondo come dei bacini separati in realtà
sono tutti parte di un unico mare
collegato tra loro dalle correnti
profonde le correnti superficiali al cui
centro c'è l'antartide che il vero e
proprio motore della circolazione
globale
per rispondere a questa domanda quindi
la plastica è arrivata fino in antartide
che ne tra il 2016 e 2017 ho avuto
l'immenso
onore la fortuna di partecipare ad una
storica spedizione di circumnavigazione
del continente antartico a bordo di
questa bellissima nave una rompighiaccio
russia academy tragico è stata la mia
casa per cinque lunghissimi mesi abbiamo
effettuato un periplo completo di tutto
il continente antartico e qui abbiamo
percorso più di 28 mila miglia qui
potete apprezzare un po la rotta che
abbiamo percorso
fermandoci a visitare una dozzina fra i
suoi antartiche sui vantaggi che fra le
isole più remote e inesplorate del
nostro pianeta
non è stato facile che sia ben chiaro a
navigare a quelle latitudini non è una
operazione semplice
tempeste gigantesche letterarie direi
con onde alte fino a 18 metri
difficoltà di tutti i tipi ma siamo
stati ripagati dalla bellezza dei posti
che vi stavamo sui quali pochi esseri
umani hanno avuto il privilegio di
posare i propri occhi
e durante la navigazione ovviamente noi
armati dei nostri retini continuiamo a
raccogliere i campioni di plancton per
cercare di capire quanta plastica
c'è in antartide
come ci arriva
in realtà la plastica e mail abbiamo
trovate anche in antartide praticamente
ovunque siamo andati seppur in
concentrazioni basse abbiamo faticato
non poco per recuperare qualche manciata
di frammenti plastici e quindi mentre
navigavamo noi eravamo
abbastanza convinti relativamente
convinti di star navigando in uno degli
oceani più puliti del mondo pensavamo di
essere in una delle ultime frontiere
dell'incontaminato
fino a che per quel bellissimo concetto
di serendipità coniato da horace walpole
a metà del 1700 per puro caso abbiamo
fatto questa scoperta e la scoperta è
avvenuta a bordo a bordo della della
rompighiaccio che vi ho fatto vedere
prima dove c'erano tantissimi altri
ricercatori che si occupavano di
studiare diciamo gli aspetti più
disparati dell'ecosistema artico e ci
hanno
loro diciamo questi colleghi sudafricani
si occupa di studiare il fitoplancton le
microalghe nei loro campioni
continuavano a vedere queste fibre
colorate queste piccole fibbie colorati
15 hanno fatte vedere ci hanno chiesto
se cosa ne pensassi se pensassimo che
fossero microfilm di plastica e noi
ovviamente abbiamo detto di sì però
molto probabilmente sono fibre plastiche
però eravamo convinti che queste fibre
derivassero da una contaminazione della
nostra nave cioè che la presa l'ha presa
male la presa d'acqua dalla quale questi
colleghi raccoglievano i loro campioni
fosse posizionata troppo vicino agli
scarichi delle lavatrici della nostra
anale noi eravamo convinti dice perché
non può non pensavamo che in antartide
in uno dei luoghi più remoti al mondo ci
potessero essere questo tipo di
inquinanti e quindi per fugare questo
dubbio per cercare di capire se
effettivamente queste fibre erano
presenti mare oppure no siamo tornati
back to basic alle basi all'inizio della
ricerca scientifica abbiamo preso un
secchio di metallo siamo nati a prua
della nostra nave durante la navigazione
abbiamo preso una secchiata d'acqua
maniera tale da essere sicuri che
stessimo prendendo dell'acqua attraverso
la quale non ha la nave non era ancora
passata e quindi incontaminata
abbiamo preso questa secchiata d'acqua
abbiamo portato in laboratorio
l'abbiamo filtrata su di un filtro
maglia molto fine e questo è quello che
mi hanno trovato non riuscivamo a
credere ai nostri occhi questo è stato
uno dei momenti più emozionanti di tutta
la mia carriera scientifica e non
riusciamo a capire come fosse possibile
che a migliaia di chilometri dalla città
più vicina ci fossero centinaia e
centinaia di piccole fibre tessili
colorate in un solo secchio d'acqua
quindi ovviamente le domande hanno
incrociato da affollarsi nella nostra
mente più raccoglievamo questi campioni
piu ci rendiamo conto che il problema
era grosso quindi io ho deciso di
rimanere a bordo un altro mese di non
sbarcare hp town in sudafrica ma di fare
di percorrere tutto l'atlantico nella
sua interezza per accompagnare la nave
nel suo viaggio di ritorno in germania
raccogliere campioni per cercare di
capire a queste fibre da dove vengono la
loro concentrazione aumenta
all'avvicinarsi dei centri di
popolazione umana oppure no e quindi
sono rimasto a bordo della nave quella
che vedete su questa mappa e la
distribuzione globale di tutti i
campioni che sono riuscito a raccogliere
nel corso di quella spedizione e poi
come vi ho detto prima le domande si
affollano
bellissimo la ricerca scientifica perché
le domande si moltiplicano sempre non si
giunge mai ad una risposta è ovviamente
ci siamo chiesti ma queste fibre
probabilmente avranno un impatto sugli
ecosistemi antartici gli organismi che
vivono in parte saranno interagendo con
queste fibre quindi abbiamo visto di di
approfondire anche questa questo
argomento e ci siamo sbarcati in questa
colonia di pinguini la colonia di
pinguini reali di saint andrews bay
pensate che questa è la colonia di
pinguini più grande del mondo su queste
colline vivono più di 100.000 pinguini
praticamente gli abitanti di una città
di medie dimensioni non è un posto
semplice deve lavorare pensate che si
sprofonda nel guano fino alle ginocchia
c'è una puzza nauseabonda bisogna farsi
largo fra decine di carcasse di pinguino
in decomposizione
però noi eravamo lì io ero personalmente
affascinato da da questa visione con una
missione cioè raccogliere dei campioni
cercare di capire se queste fibre
stessero permeando l'ecosistema mi ha
raccolto i nostri campioni abbiamo
analizzato in laboratorio
ovviamente non mi dilungo ma anche nel
guano di pinguini abbiamo ritrovato
tantissimo fibre tessili
da dove vengono queste fibre e
probabilmente ne avete già sentito
parlare tutti sicuramente le lavatrici
sono una delle fonti primarie pensate
che un singolo ciclo di lavaggio di capi
d'abbigliamento di uso comune o
rilasciare qualche milione di fibra
nelle acque di scarico che se non
trattate adeguatamente finiranno
inevitabilmente i mari i fiumi e poi mai
ma se ci pensate pensateci bene
la quantità di tessile che ci circonda
nelle nostre vite quotidiane è
gigantesca pensate ad una bandiera che
si sfilaccia nel vento pensate adesso a
quante bandiere ogni giorno sventolano
sulla poppa delle navi e delle
imbarcazioni il mondo pensate a quante
bandiere si vendono sventolano sui sulle
facciate dei palazzi delle scuole dei
dei comuni di tutto il mondo
o pensate invece al pulviscolo quello
che si deposita sugli schermi delle
nostre televisioni o dei nostri computer
altro non sono che piccole fibre tessili
e provate a pensare a quante lenzuola
tappezzerie tappeti tovaglie e tessili
di tutti i colori e materiali ci
circonda nella nostra vita quotidiana
moltiplicate questi numeri per 8
miliardi di abitanti di questo pianeta
avrete un'idea del problema il problema
è enorme è vastissimo e spesso quando
racconto dei risultati delle mie
ricerche mi inevitabilmente mi viene
chiesto ma cosa possiamo fare quali sono
le soluzioni io personalmente non ne ho
di soluzioni io mi occupo di descrivere
quella che è la situazione del nostro
mare
e poi ci sono tantissimi colleghi
preparatissimi che lavorano stanno
lavorando in questi in questi giorni a
trovare delle soluzioni
mi piace però solo concludere
ricordandovi che
possiamo applicare in qualsiasi ambito
della nostra vita famosissimo principio
delle tre m cioè ridurre riutilizzare
riciclare il più possibile quindi
consumare di meno comprare di meno
lavare di meno e con la consapevolezza
che se moltiplicate per 8 miliardi di
persone le conseguenze delle nostre
azioni per quanto piccole si siano
spesso diventano molto più evidenti
anche a decine di migliaia di chilometri
dalle nostre lavatrice grazie
[Applauso]